you want your friends to rise
in whatever ranks it is but
there's a degree of their rise where
they're like [ __ ] that guy everyone does
that it's just it's uh it's hard to get
away from i don't know for some reason i
want to pull you down yes they're crabs
in a bucket yeah yeah i mean at some
point well and then society
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god
your voicemail would you send us
so
there's a couple of them let's see which
ones are the best ones oh [ __ ] the one
you did on the phone
when you left so jack nicholson and joe
press you go to the laker game back in
the in the 2000s
and uh they're sitting there the big
deal because jack's always there joe has
his hat he's sitting there like that you
know and then when they go to uh after
the game they go home to jack
nicholson's house press you met him
there and they go inside and uh and uh
jack nicholson goes
i'm gonna have to ask you to leave
and he goes why you [ __ ] and he
goes because i have a young lady coming
over
and i to go upstairs and make myself
presentable
and uh joe fashion she goes why are you
[ __ ] she's not coming over here
to [ __ ] you she's coming over here to
[ __ ] jack nicholson you don't care about
[ __ ] what you look like how you smell
what the [ __ ] you're wearing and jackos
nonetheless
[Laughter]
and then he goes hey jack you ever use
viagra and he goes only when i'm
outnumbered
he's got
[ __ ] all over his nose his shirt's all
white and he's
so on a saturday afternoon about four
o'clock 4 15 i'm on the
10th 11th 12th 13th hole the one that
goes uphill yeah yeah back yeah i went
through the tree there and and i'm in
the middle there that [ __ ] ball comes
flying over my head and there's nobody
out there right you know it's a late
afternoon nobody goes out there and in a
no top like the ones i use i look over
and jack has a shirt that's like stuck
to him because of all his sweat yeah i
just stuck to him
[ __ ] coke dust right here [ __ ]
coke rings
hair back like wet back and he and he
goes we're going to play through george
i said yeah
yeah
i said hey go ahead yeah go go go go
and then i went down to look how far
they were [ __ ] gone
these [ __ ] went
i said like in greece they just [ __ ]
took off
kept going yeah but dave jack was a
[ __ ] trip because
he wasn't that good
and he never played 18 in a row
well he just bounced around pesch does
that now
like pesh kind of just will do like you
know
three here two there yeah and then
circle back sometimes sometimes i'll see
him sitting in the sand trap for like 15
minutes just messing up so so i remember
this one so junior the sky junior but
like 25 years ago i think he's been
there that long and uh it was his first
week and jack nicholson goes in and he's
smoking
a cigarette in the pro shop and junior's
like [ __ ] do i say i mean
you know he goes hey mr nicholson
um you can't smoke in the pro shop or
what
yeah
he's like uh
oh or you know
the police he goes i'll take my chance
right
yeah and then the next the next
afternoon
who walks through the [ __ ] pro shop
with you [ __ ] pesci you spoke with a
cigarette brother i heard you can't
smoke it this [ __ ]
or what what will happen nothing hey i
heard you can't smoke in this
[ __ ] [ __ ] flowers you've
seen that clip of chappelle when he
first came back and he was in a
like i think he was at the comedy store
in london you know the london comedy
store which has no affiliation to ours
but there's like a real low ceiling and
his eyes are kind of you can't really
see much you know like the the spot is
really bright
and some guy in the back is is yelling
he's like you can't smoke you can't
smoke and he's like what he's like you
you can't smoke she was like no
[ __ ] you can't smoke in here
like nothing ever happened it was great
i mean the crowd went ape [ __ ] i [ __ ]
lost it it's true some people can smoke
inside some people can smell he smokes
he smokes inside everywhere he still
comes to the common store and smokes
inside who's going to do like two hours
the last time i saw him at the club
it was maybe two
and some change i used to [ __ ] do two
hours i couldn't beg for my [ __ ] life
for two hours yeah i'd be like you know
[ __ ] just kill me man 45 50
minutes maybe not two hours nuts two
hours forget i would do two and i would
do two an hour 45 yeah
[ __ ] and then and big places they would
be like uh what are you gonna do man i
said you know set the clock at hour 45
or an hour 30 yeah then i'll get off at
hour 45. i did a [ __ ] live hbo
special 85 minutes that's so much i
couldn't do it again that's so much to
do for a special because for a special
your energy is through the roof you're
doing so much more than you need to do
when you do a special because your mind
is racing like you're overthinking all
of the bits making sure that every all
the puzzle pieces when you're doing a
live show show
i go long on shows just if you're having
fun right but in a special mindset your
brain is like i need to knock out these
things and they told me you have to be
done
between 85 and 90 or else guess what
happens i go what they [ __ ]
cut go to [ __ ] yeah they cut
somewhere baker with a rubber red for
him
but it's a lot i i i did them live
because i thought
how can you make stand-up like more
risky yeah and i said you know how you
can you do a special live yeah it is
where i don't think you could do it now
because [ __ ] would be in there
trying to [ __ ] with you
yeah also there's no respect yeah with
the internet now yeah so it's just the
game is different on where specials go
so live was like
it was a must-see event like people had
to go watch it
now the internet is like i'll see it
whenever i'm ready i know yeah it's up
to the audience now which is kind of i
mean it's good but
you have almost no control on
programming when somebody's like it
comes out wednesday and people are like
no it doesn't comes out whenever i watch
it that's right you know in people's
mind they're like it comes out when i
need to say and then they look at
ratings like uh three and seven days or
14 days where before it was solely like
when my show started just on tv there
was streaming
there wasn't uh you know even that was
the beginning of
of um
reality tv yeah that's why you know i i
i don't know maybe just me because i'm
not in the business at all but it seems
that all the good specials yeah but
you're dressed like you're in the busy
[Laughter]
they uh
all the good they're taking their skin
both
i love that
they're [ __ ] virgins all the good the
the big comedians you know they did the
special they started coming out and
everybody wanted to watch them now it
just seems like they have maybe i'm
getting older they have more more
specials it's like when you order this
with less known companies
would you like to try our specials today
what are they fried chicken and a
hamburger they're [ __ ] special every
day wow i mean you know they're not
special
they're not special and the comedians
are using
are not that
i don't say they're not that good
they're just not that's what he's saying
that's what he's saying
hey i'm not the one that got shot at by
one of his old men
all right so
last week
it was a chip it was a chippy
i don't remember the dude didn't shoot
you when you had pulled a gun on the
ground officers
[ __ ] that was years ago yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you know he caught the nightstalker
right
wait who did yeah
you did so gil was a sheriff you uh
for so he
go through the whole thing no we're not
pretty good so so he was he was on the
streets and up in east l.a in that area
up there hussein heights and and a cop
said hey man did you to your parents and
never
and said
this kid either gets off the street or
he's going to end up dead and they're
going to go [ __ ] somewhere and he
went to bed and he [ __ ] went to
vietnam yeah
17 they signed me aside from me get off
the streets you're gonna in a prison day
vietnam and so then i i ended up in
vietnam come back and
things turned around and it was all good
it's been a good life since i remember
how long were you in vietnam i was there
for a year
is that was that what a tour was a year
tour was a year and those chicken chips
in the army
they sent me back on emergency leave
you know in january my grandmother
passed away
and my grandmother passed away and my
sister was a good liar on her feet
because they went and they told the red
cross hey can you let him know his red
cross
and she said they said yes but you
understand unless the grandmother had
raised him that won't allow him to come
back for the funeral and she said that's
the only reason i'm here telling you
because she did raise it well my grandma
never raised me
and so they sent word back to my unit
my unit then says okay and that's all
you needed was word back then you didn't
need to say yeah
now you need a death certificate yeah no
they just said hey we got this news for
you your grandmother died and we've just
been we had had the [ __ ] shot out of us
the night before
we're going back to pick up parts and
they said hey come in here the first pig
wants to talk to hey do you know julia
castro i said yes
they said well we're here
sorry
i'm just telling my family from the time
i was 11 years old yeah i don't know how
how we started doing this but if
somebody was talking about a girl i
would say does he have big titties yeah
but this is probably 60 years by the
time i was 11. and they would pull me
out of the cloud they'd get me like this
outside i heard you outside the real
question
yeah he's got me saying it now
and if i don't do it
it's going to end the longest streak
that i think other than
that
but but i mean so they sent me home
that's what i yeah they tell you she was
there they they said you can you want to
go home and i'm saying i'm biting myself
on the cheek with the inside
yes
yeah yeah so they sent me home and they
said we've got your personnel files
right here we pulled them all out
because you've only got another month
left in country
probably won't send you back to finish
that one month in country
so they send me back with all my all my
papers i went back i remember my mom
cried she found my she found my personal
jacket because it was in with my dirty
clothes she could wash my clothes she
found she started reading them and she
didn't realize i had lied to everybody
back here they never knew i was in
combat you know what i was doing and now
they've got the stuff they're reading
their medals and yeah and so now
you know i said mom it's okay i don't
have to go back i'm done
they're not gonna send me back then i
get this [ __ ] letter it says
ah no you to go back they made me go
back for another month
that made you do the whole 12 months
they made me do the whole 12 months i
sent me back to vietnam
give me another month i was due to come
back february i got there first week of
february
1968 right at the beginning of 10
offensive so i'm doing it come back the
first week of february and instead they
held me there until march
you know what man i don't know what i
would do i mean i love this country but
but i'm not sure
what i would do like i'm not made for
[Laughter]
he doesn't want to admit it he's a
reserve he's a national guard yeah i'm
i'm still in rotc i think i'm i'm just
in there
but
was it was kind of like the the minor
leagues for for the military yeah yeah
they get you into school farm league
yeah and you're marching on the football
field and [ __ ] while everybody's out
there talking to chicks at lunch yeah my
buddy did that was my first roommate in
college he was rotc and got kicked out
got kicked out of school and the rotc
which is hard to do because the rotc
needs your ass to stay they need people
better you do
never showed up showed up drunk if he
did show up was drunk and never showed
up so he'd have his you know he'd have
superior yelling at him come come and
get him out of his dorm room he i mean
his whole life was needed structure so
it was good but it never worked for this
dude because nothing was gonna fix him
he was on his own little planet so so so
guys that are on their own little planet
and then they go to the military and
they got long hair and they cut their
hair and then they kind of deprogrammed
you right where you laughed and the guy
[ __ ] kicked you in your ass you were
laughing at him and he's like what the
[ __ ] are you laughing at yeah yeah and
so they're breaking you down and then
you become we all become the same we all
yeah you know and then all the same they
give you you think the same they i don't
know propaganda what they do to you but
all of a sudden
it's the army way and you got to do it
that way you know you believe in it you
believe and it's not till after i came
back that i was in germany and i said
you know war is hell there are no
winners in war nobody wins either side
nobody wins everybody has people dying
everybody has family people that love
them and yet
we go over there and we do this because
they're asking us to
you know and and you don't think twice
about it when you're in the middle of it
man all you can think about hey we've
got to take care of business you know
you're
guarding your partner you're guarding
you you want to stay alive you're
fighting to stay alive how often were
you scared were you scared ever
can you forget that you're in vietnam no
by just doing your job i don't think i
don't think you could no yeah because
when you every day you look out yeah
it's there
it's there i had an old pilot
uh that had seen me on television doing
police work here through the department
he got in touch with me and he said
i had to talk to you he says weren't you
weren't you ever afraid because all you
did was laugh
he says that's all you ever did here and
i was a crew chief on a helicopter so
essentially when you're up there flying
you're shooting a gun that's all you're
doing
and he says and we've been through some
heavy stuff
and i said you know mr johnson i can
still hear you saying oh my god oh my
god oh my god he's in a hover hole
oh my god oh my god i can hear you
saying oh my god oh my god oh my god he
says and all i can hear you is laughing
saying
it's okay mr johnson they're just
throwing softballs at us you just keep
flying you're doing good you know and
and he got us out of it and i owe the
guy my life you know he's the one that
got us up and out of it we're taking all
this [ __ ] those were before black hawk
those were just those were just i know
those are those are like the the
the hyundai's yeah the sky yeah well
they didn't even bring them back that
after aircraft carrier they ditched them
in the water yeah they got rid of it
they threw them in the water and i think
that's too stupid to be afraid you know
and i not sit there
after you you're going hot then you
you're breaking away because you're
gonna come back and make another and
you're saying oh dear god just let me
get through this one come on you know
please god help me out you know you get
through it on the way back
and but once you were away from it
you're all good it doesn't matter just
like walking down the block again well a
bunch of young kids is all i can ever
think about it's like are you sneaking
away trying to see girls ever
over there or yeah over there no never
no no you're gonna leave though well no
i take that back yes i was gonna say so
it's about a 19 year old boy oh yeah you
go into town
and
it was restricted because it was a heavy
fortified vc bait you know where we were
at a lot of so you're allowed to go into
open storefronts if there were stores
you weren't allowed to go off the street
and really if you had the time and i
didn't get to go into town that often
but when you did you couldn't wait to
get off the streets right you know just
go catch a little you know
bang bang yeah
uh good morning vietnam uh robin
williams yeah the way the kids steal
[ __ ] that's just the way they were
you know and i didn't realize that you
know you think the little pieces of [ __ ]
well they're they're doing what they got
to do to get by so we'd go buy it and
get boxes of c rations
and
put what was in those
oh c rash were canned meats
ham and eggs
meatloaf bone chicken
uh there were vegetables in them some of
that [ __ ] was good
as i said i guess some of it's got to be
all right yeah i trade around i love the
ham and eggs and it so it's in like a
tin and you open it and you heat it or
you just open it good if you had time to
heat it you'd eat it sometimes you
didn't and you had these little uh
p-38s they're a little can opener just a
little small thing
around a little key like yeah open it up
eat your stuff so you take a case of
them in a case there was 12 boxes of sea
rations
and so
you'd leave the box
in the back of the jeep or the back of
the truck
so they could see that it was there
knowing that they're going to steal it
oh yeah as i could just take it yeah
firearms
no you put a smoke grenade in there
that's awesome yeah
open the box
that's like when you're going to rob a
bank of them you go look at everybody
pam yeah right [ __ ] dialogue put
smoke on them or give them uh they love
candy so xlax your mix likes
[Laughter]
your different it's a different world
you know when you're doing that stuff
yeah and just watch and they run around
they'd run fast they're no way this fat
ass ever gonna get i was thin then but
i'm not gonna chase anybody so they'd
run and then you hear
and then you can see the smoke coming up
and then yeah and then you'd see them
run around you know about that new
number 10 gi you know and then you know
pumping you off
but didn't hurt anybody it was just just
for fun yeah how old were you how old
were you i was 18. i just turned 18. 18.
i turned 18 november 29th and i was
there the first week of february what
did you do on your 18th birthday do you
remember
on the actual day of like you were
probably still in high school right yeah
i was a senior in high school you
remember granted i haven't remember what
did you do
i went to buffalo wild wings and
that sounds about right sure maybe we
went to hooters i'm almost positive we
went to hooters my buddy's dad i mean i
was interested i was in uh chicken wings
i was in fort stewart georgia
i was in the army by myself you know
what i did huh i went with the guys i
was playing baseball with april 23rd the
day of my 18th birthday went to
hollywood boulevard to the pussycat
theater and we watched deep throat and
the devil in his jones [ __ ] cochinole
still in high school man my heroes and
then we had the first baseman eddie
rico's big dude and he would laugh like
and when they were [ __ ] he would just
be laughing like hey shut the [ __ ] up
you've never seen i don't know no i've
never seen a porno how was deep throat
it's like the iconic one but i don't
know how many people actually see it
it's a good movie
tons of people saw that right it
happened
it was on hollywood boulevard
yeah that kind of [ __ ] soundtrack by the
way
i got to give the other side of it okay
so i messed with the kids
nothing serious never hurt anybody were
you gonna go and get some americans
what i did
helped start an orphanage over there
and i wrote back the city that i grew up
in peace what do you mean you left all
the kids in one [ __ ] little house
yeah no no they were finished they were
living
my heart when we saw these little kids
it's awful eight eight years old
teaching them how to protect their
village
you know with oozies and any gun that
they can get their hands on
so then the guys that i was flying with
everybody just took it upon themselves
wrote home i wrote home to my family of
pico they put it in the local pico press
here on the pickle paper
and asking for help so i got clothes and
stuff sent to me we helped start a
village a little orphanage back there
the orphanage is still in existence
today wow they're still supported by the
same guys that uh same kids are there
they're [ __ ] 75 years old yeah yeah
yeah
they never got out of the way
one of the kids was a little girl
that is now uh married alive and well
living in honeymoon
[Laughter]
and uh probably long nipples but not
nothing yeah yeah happy heavy long
nipples she uh
she's wanted to thank people you know
because she made it out you know she was
part of the orphanage
and she's here now she's wild that's
insane do you ever go in the middle of
the night and scare her
[Laughter]
hey so so
um
i don't know man i just don't i you know
it's fine i'm not fascinated by by
asking you because
i know i know that i
i'm not sure
there were no like um
ied like another stuff like they had in
afghanistan where you're walking and you
blow up no and and i didn't worry about
that i you know they didn't booby trap
back they had mine back then
i was up and i was up in helicopter you
know so
land to get back to my hooch and the
only time i was ever in the vehicle was
when we had to go pick up more
ammunition or go make a trash would you
take food to the guys pick up trash like
get down low dump all the [ __ ] maybe
take a guy with you and get the [ __ ] out
of there like fly in and fly out no no
no i'm take that's the only time i was
in a vehicle
in a helicopter two kinds i was there
number one for the first seven months i
was in what we call slicks these are
huey helicopters
that would go in we would resupply take
them either food their mail ammunition
new troops we would extract old troops
wounded troops dead troops
so insertion extraction that's what we
did at one time we were flying uh
defoliation you know this agent orange
that you hear about they put a big
[ __ ] bladder inside the helicopter oh
my god sprayers out there no and then
we'd ride
fly over rice paddies matter of fact
that's the only time i ever saw
somebody that i ever shot
because when you people are shooting at
you you're shooting back all you're
seeing is muzzle flashes well now i'm
flying over a rice paddy right by the
end of these dikes that are in between
them as we're going all of us and you're
flying slow
you're low and slow and all of a sudden
some little ding jumps up
hit the helicopter at least three or
four times before i reacted
and i hit him and when i hit him and he
flew bam
he flipped and fell and went back down
and as soon as that happens
you immediately have to drop smoke to
mark the spot and then you pull up and
out
and then the gun ships that are flying
escort for you they come in
with mini guns and rockets and
so that day
i just made a decision man i'm tired of
running every time you get shot you got
to run the gun big boys with the guns
come in
so i went and i said i want to fly guns
so i went to gunships
and never saw another
vietnamese soldier or anybody south
vietnamese vc north vietnamese that i
hit
but then i did that's the only one i
ever saw country the rest of time is all
gunships so there's a reason for tracer
fire so they can see where they're where
they're shooting
yeah you want to say something you can
my memory served me correctly it's every
fifth or every tenth round as a tracer
oh i didn't know that yeah
so you so the other guys would come in
after you guys to clean up huh
they would
we didn't go in to clean up nobody went
in to clean up you did what you had to
do and then finish up if there was would
they go in to make sure there was no
other soldiers there is that why they
were backing up no why would they come
in after you guys then when you put the
gun chips as soon as you'd mark the spot
where it happened yeah first thing you
do is you you know
incoming or
shots fired and then i would throw one
there'd be another slick behind me
he was gonna
so
they the gunships we would then pull out
the gunships in okay somewhere between
the two smokes that's where the enemy
was just
so they just come in with miniguns and
rockets what was the caliber what were
you shooting i was using m60
7.62 rounds
and the m16 was uh 5.62 and it was every
five rounds for tracers yeah
and what's overstepple the thing yeah
and they said with that 50 caliber gun
with a sniper even if it misses somebody
if it goes by them it'll sear their skin
oh yeah that's going so fast 50 calibers
is
snuggly big vicious weapon you know we
could never shoot something like that
you know with what we had that's a big
isn't it it's huge isn't it big massive
yeah you see you see them you can't
believe they go they go in and come out
of a [ __ ] gun that's so big
those guys i did the harry truman out
there in the ocean a couple years ago
and i shot the 50 caliber and you're not
even looking you know the ship the gun
is out there but you're in here looking
at a screen and you have the red thing
and you look and you'll say fire and you
just shoot into the thing but i go what
do you see out here goes ah
those guys are like oh man we see some
somali pirates and they try to come at
us and like what are you guys to go
he goes jordan they
they disappear like in a puff of bread
like [ __ ] they just they're gone yeah
they disintegrate and they don't give a
[ __ ] they brother
bullets
yeah they ride up on us and he goes they
ride up on us and these dinky ass
[ __ ] things and they start shooting
like you're pop pop and they're like are
they [ __ ] shooting those guys have
balls man they run up on the biggest
ships
yeah they do
we had uh we went you hear that somali
pirates
you guys are gonna have shoes they don't
run it up on our boats
flying guns they gave us a mission it
was to search and destroy pack elephants
the north vietnamese and south koreans
were using elephants
to transport their food and ammunition
their weapons so they said okay here's
where they're last seen there's a group
go out there so we go out we shoot
elephants shoot elephants and we went
out and what we did was we had white
phosphorus willie peter in the rockets
so you'd go in here
light it up this way light it up this
way make another run and light it up
that way so the only way the elements
can get out is oh my god you'd pull them
out
yeah and they'd say okay here they go
here they come you guys get them first
so they allowed us and we had free
wheeling 60s you guys get them and and
remember this is so so there's smoke
there's there's smoke here and they're
looking they see smoke and they don't
see smoke there so they're running
they're running out right towards you
towards towards the open door
and
this is i think that's better than the
circus huh yeah this is not for bottom
belly take notes man remember this is
war you know and it's not something that
i would ever do or think of or yeah no
no don't don't write me letters animal
activists but they're coming out and
then the fighters thought okay you guys
get first crack so we're shooting our
free wheeling 60s at them and you hit
them and a 60 on that elevator just like
flies you know yeah he's going to say
that that can't hurt him that much that
involved he said okay
your turns up now our turn then they'd
come in and they'd hit them with rockets
but
all that ever happened with rockets is
they they hit right below and the
elephant just you just see the elephant
just go boom fall over yeah fall over
sideways dead dead like shocked hit i
don't know what the [ __ ] is we're gonna
go down we weren't gonna go down with
the stethoscope yeah yeah we'll just
take its pulse
see how it is there's no heads
they go for the legs though that's all
nobody's calling code blue well with
rockets you're just shooting at it yeah
you're aiming at anything close and
back then the
the sights for rockets
weren't that really this was the site
for the rock this was the site and what
you would do is they put a little circle
with an x on the on the windshield
oh my god
okay
yeah yeah they would just move it if it
was off right now you put that sticker
over here you name it you name it uh
over there so you have to be more of a
marksman than than
i would say now maybe yeah you'd have to
shoot it okay let's see where that okay
now let's try it again
uh i'm even i'm like googling this as
you're talking about it i'm not even
finding a lot of results about people
talking about shooting elephants yeah
and the v like i'm sure they didn't brag
about it but like
i'm sure that was breaking news i'm sure
that was military
i'm sure that was military secrets i
mean that was like you know talk about
nothing i mean and it's
and i emphasized that was war not
something that should be done you know
you talk about
it was ugly there are no winners in war
did you ever have to hand to hand
somebody no no street fight no no no no
you think it was safer in the air than
it was on the ground oh i do you
actually feel that right that's what my
first thought was because
i think just the opposite they were
scared to death of being in the air
and this fat ass didn't want to be in
the jungle with scorpions
i'm with you
put me in the sky
i'd come home you know i'd land re-arm
refuel and then go back to my hooch
where i had a cotton had a you know so
you'd be away yeah but then also there'd
be guys behind you bigger
bigger
bigger helicopters behind you or
in the slicks
yeah you always had
gunship escorts
you know you always had these gunships
escorting with you
and when you're in gun ships you know
[ __ ] follow you you're just gunnies
you're not going to be you're not going
to be going down and landing you're just
going to be flying and shooting and
coming back home how many of those
things just fell on the uh just
malfunctioned and crashed on their own
did that happen a lot or no
uh no it's not either pilot error they
got shut down they don't fall down their
own so you could they could shoot at you
and penetrate the the gas oh [ __ ] yeah
so the helicopter is just thin you know
yeah it wouldn't [ __ ]
that i guess that's what i mean is like
those things must have been
i mean no one's checking them down every
time you take them off right you're just
going
are the mechanics there wasn't much yeah
yeah yeah we we're no we're checking
them oh you are yeah every day the crew
chief that was my job i'd get out there
and check the helicopter out make sure
that it's all it's flyable right i'm
gonna get in it it's gonna be flyable
right and you get it up you get in the
air if it took rounds well then you come
back and now they got to patch those
rounds up and they got to make sure we
didn't hit anything
there's a few spots you know you if you
lose an engine you can still go down you
just got to find a place to land it
uh you lose your tail rotor
you're done
unless you got a long runway to go to
your
your toast you know the drive shaft
going to the rotor you know there's a
few places that are really vulnerable
especially if you hit the pilot there
were some dudes that were that were shot
down that got some some pilots that got
held as prisoners right yes yes and you
parade them through the street of the
latino guy yeah there was uh
several of them most of them were uh
fighter jet jockeys because you know
they're they're the ones that got shot
down they saw him coming down
uh not many people
survived helicopter crashes you know as
much it's a shorter time to get to the
ground right yeah you fall out of a
plane you've got you don't have
parachutes right parachutes there's not
one parachute on a helicopter no damn
but i think when you hit i might bring
my own
like what's up with that backpack i'm
like no i just have a backpack
it comes out
armor plating and flak jackets
right and i never wore it
you know because you thought you sat on
them i sat uh did you ever
let me ask you this did you wear it
because you couldn't button it or
because
no i don't have an extension
seat belt i've got your extender for the
you know they're coming from below
they're not going to know
i think it's better to sit on them
up there it goes through the helicopter
in your ass exactly
and you're [ __ ] nuts in your [ __ ]
nuts
god forbid why would you want to live if
that happened did you ever see someone
get shot in a helicopter next year or
near you i my gunner got shot he took
one in the back but he would he live
yeah he got sent back to the united
states i
i'm i'm assuming i used to work during
the day in northridge at uh
that place telling ir whatever the [ __ ]
that was um there was a guy named dennis
stapp s-t-a-p-p
and he was kind of short guy with a
beard and he walked you know little
thing but just a roly-poly type dude and
then we were talking about him
and they said you know dennis was in
vietnam and i said dennis was in vietnam
yeah he was a tail gunner on a
helicopter
so we used to go to lunch and walking
over
and uh
i said hey man you're in vietnam he goes
yeah i was a tail gunner so what is that
i shot you know cleared the roads we
want to shot anything that moved you
know the the tanks were going down there
and we had to clear the way
i said you shoot kids he goes maybe i
just shot
wherever protect either them or me right
i said you never had any nightmares or
anything he goes
no i was doing my job
i was just going right throughout my wow
that's what i was paid to do it's gonna
be me or them it's not gonna be me the
only nightmares i've ever had about that
that place is i'm stealing a helicopter
is what is it
stealing stealing hill i wanted to fly
so badly i learned how to fly when i was
there oh wow but i wanted to fly so bad
i'd always in in mine i'm always
stealing a helicopter i'm getting a base
and i'm stealing him i'm starting up and
i'm taking off that's your dream all of
you would you dream still today about
yeah yeah i still dream
let's get you a [ __ ] helicopter
let's go steal one i love it
yeah butterflies when i worked homicide
we had our murder scenes i would always
go up in the bird and take my own
pictures you know it's like bird does
bird fly helicopters
no no no
no
oh yeah yeah he's just about to take
like uh some right before covert and
then and then he's been studying but
then he had to put it off but yeah he's
very very into it he's he's the kind of
guy that's going to get it and then buy
his own fleet of helicopters you know
yeah because he's he's so into it for a
long time he was talking about how much
he loved it and then yeah he was going
to take a final exam to fly
independently
and covet hit yeah because i i don't it
was it's a ton of hours i remember he
told me one time it's an insane
amount of stuff you have to do to get
approved that was one of the reasons i
really wanted to be a deputy
only because they took their pilots from
within the rank and file they wanted to
have their pilots they wanted to
bring them in and they were already
indoctrinated you know into law
enforcement work
and i ended up going as my career went
on
my dream was eventually to get the
homicide bureau i didn't make it i
didn't get the arrow bureau
i wanted to go to homicide bureau a good
buddy of mine went through the academy
together were patrol together he went to
aero bureau
and he had been a marine corps fighter
pilot
and so he's over at arrow bureau and he
flies a helicopter flies fixed wing and
one time he had to fly me up to san jose
on a case
and it's just him and i ain't playing
the fix wing
and he says hey kill he says you want to
take off we're flying out of long beach
do you want to take off
and i said yeah
so there it is man pulled back i got it
pulled up and we're flying and i'm god
this is the greatest [ __ ] feeling i'm
up and away so i said okay you got it
and he took it back
and i said you know god damn it
there's only one job
i would leave homicide bureau for i said
not for arrow to become a pilot oh [ __ ]
i didn't know that never got it yeah and
he says you know there's only one job
i'd leave arrow bureau for
and that's the lateral over to homicide
bureau
and he says unfortunately for the both
of us he says
i'm not a good investigator and you're
even worse as a pilot so we better just
keep our [ __ ] yeah where you are yeah
were you into are you into crime like a
lot of people are in the car you know
what's so funny is i i my
i have cops and firefighters all in my
family because i'm an irish
you know trash bag from chicago so it's
like your home
that's all your whole family is cops and
firefighters
but i i never liked to hear about it
because then i thought then i then i
would know someone that was going to get
hurt i would always every time i heard
about like cops getting shot and stuff
like that i always
gave me the [ __ ] creeps because i
thought about my family and then i was
like man what if it's somebody i know
because i knew too we know too many cops
so i always got scared about hearing
homicides who's going to take a shot
what criminals going to take a shot at a
police officer because if you're a
criminal you know today i shoot a
[ __ ] cop i'm i'm and they get me
there today they do it today they don't
have it today
they don't give a [ __ ] i mean two
chicago cops just got killed
and one of them got shot with their own
gun they went out on
a domestic dispute call i think it was
something about a dog or something and
it was just the news it was [ __ ] tragic
and
they went in there to investigate i
think it was a domestic call i might be
wrong but whatever the case
and uh you know whatever why are those
the the most frightening ones the
domestic because you got a guy that's
irrational they're fighting he's all
popped down you don't know what he's on
yeah you go to hook him and then you got
to worry about the wife jumping on your
back because she really didn't want him
to go because that's the breadwinner of
the family and i love him and yeah
they call them they call the cops to and
then they want to hurt the cops when
they get there because they're afraid
they're going to lose and and plus it's
tough because you don't know what's
going through his mind yeah i ain't
going back to the joint i ain't doing
this right this is he under the
influence
it's a tough world and with everybody
looking at you today it's a tough tell
me tell me this is this is true i saw
this the other day on the internet there
was a video compilation of cops patrol
cops when they pulled people over they
touched the back of the car have you
ever seen this do you know what this is
for have you ever heard of this or seen
this like leave a thumb print yeah i
never knew that
so i there's a video a bunch of cops
when they patrol and they pull people
over they put their hand on the trunk
which is wild because i remember being
pulled over and i he tapped my trunk
twice wow and i was like why why i was
like why did you just touch a trunk
he rolled right through the question but
that was what it said online was to
leave fingerprints in case something
happened i just you know never heard of
that no see cops are 38 38 years but
in hindsight the way things are now
maybe that's why not a bad move like the
yeah yeah so you heard of it too right
they leave yeah i've never heard of that
i don't know how just in case some [ __ ]
goes wrong look it's probably just
something that if that's not true it
sounds too you know it's like yeah it
sounds too true that you're like it is
true to me it's true sounds like
something they ought to be training the
academy yeah serious business sure
because then you find the car and you go
to the thing and exactly you know you
gotta you can see it sometimes yeah my
wife is into all that stuff that like
murder mystery and all that [ __ ] you
like that i can't i can't do it man see
i don't have but you know
i don't like any of it yeah i mean i
think you were too close to it now maybe
i just think about it yeah chicago was
like not
it's a it was just it's just it's just i
didn't like the stories because i was
like is that gonna be someone i know but
she loves that shirt
it is it's gotten way worse now
cops were not so
mario the guy that had the place on uh
sunset you know he had the roxy
and the other place right next door
uh the rainbow the rainbow who's that
mario mario i can't remember his last it
was an italian and they just opened one
about 10 years ago over in vegas but
then he died uh but he had the ones
right there he's an old chicago cop
as the story goes he was a money man for
the judge
and got all that money that he had left
over came over here and turned it into a
legitimate business
and he was from chicago michael mann
when he made the movie heat yeah
michael mann's from chicago
and he had a captain out here from
chicago
and they asked me if i'd help him out
doing interviews you know uh
teaching pacino and these guys you know
how to do some interviews
and i told michael mann i said i can't
do it with this guy i mean this guy's
from chicago they put their hands on
people we don't do that [ __ ] out here
and he said i just go out there and do
it so we're doing this interview
and he brought with him a buddy from
chicago who's an old chicago wise guy
and he's sitting there and i'm talking
about i say hey what's your name bill
bill do you have a last name yeah what's
your last name smith do you have middle
name yeah and he's just making
everything hard
and i'm starting to get a kcs i'm saying
look i ain't got time to be [ __ ]
around here you know we're gonna
straighten this [ __ ] out just then my
beeper goes off
uh my pager we used to use pagers oh
yeah and i had some guy covering an
autopsy for me
because all of a sudden this cop the
retired captain reaches over and smacks
this guy right across the [ __ ] chops
hard
and i said uh excuse me i'm going to go
answer this page
and there's a wall right there and i
answer the [ __ ] page
and it's bobby tucson bobby says hey gil
just like you said it was a through and
through the head you know no big and
then he could hear this guy screaming
and he said what's that where you at
give me the dress where are you at we're
rolling and i said no no i'm on a movie
said it's okay bobby what this captain
has done is he's reached out he's got a
handful of the guys nuts
and he says you have something we want
and i've got something you want oh my
god
and then the guy he asks him another
question
and he squeezes more and the guy blood
curdling scream and tucson's saying god
damn it gil give me an address we'll
roll anybody
i'm saying no no and then michael mann
finally hear michael man saying all
right cut cut
okay that was good that was i said you
see just the movie said bobby it's it's
okay
but he's grabbing this dude's nuts from
yeah boys no thanks
there was an actor in that movie i don't
want to say who it is because i don't
even give permission but
he told me that he used to be used to do
strong armed robberies then he turned
into an actor
and they shot at bob big boy on on
riverside
and he was in there shooting the movie
and he was looking around
and he put his head down he goes i think
i [ __ ] robbed this place
and he goes i wonder if they [ __ ] if
the managers or people here are gonna
[ __ ] i know that i know who you're
talking about yeah and i know you're
talking about and i we interviewed him
he said hey [ __ ]
he said yeah yeah
he's on it man he's like can i get you
guys anything nothing no no we're good
okay
i'm looking at this guy
and i'm talking and i'm saying now look
at me
look at me
do i have a tattoo of a pee on my
forehead and he said no i says because
i'm not a pendejo
i said now [ __ ] you better start
and this guy's breaking out in the sweat
and michael mann finally said okay cut
cut excellent excellent
and he comes up to me like man [ __ ]
sweating yeah great job right he says i
haven't been swimming like that man that
was like the real thing i haven't been
sweated like that in a long time
you know and
pacino comes
gail that was [ __ ] great you do great
ass no this is a [ __ ] living for me
brother yeah that was the reality yeah
yeah the same the same acting this was
the real deal so i remember when you
said i know who you got to be talking
about now
you never got shot at did you as a cop
or yeah i
guys and by another cop by his own and
he just [ __ ] he happened to just miss
him yeah he's trying to hit him
uh it was just
no controversy short version
he thought we were bad guys we were
playing clothes he thought we were bad
guys and we had guns out and so
he was telling us thankfully he's a bad
shot huh thankfully you know he was
saying drop your guns i'm saying is he
talking to us
and his partner who knew who we were
said it's okay they're cops because i
don't know who they are drop your guns
and he yells back he says hey they're
sheriffs because i don't know who they
are drop your boom and he fired holy
[ __ ] and i said holy [ __ ] i said a lot
more than holy [ __ ] did you shoot back
no i'm shooting right back like an
elephant that's why i can't be a cop
shoot until i get you i had already
thrown my gun on the ground but like an
elephant i jumped over the car got on
the other side my partner who was pissed
i had another gun strapped to my leg and
i just said it's okay we're back here if
we pull he's going to shoot again i'll
dump him yeah and i knew i i was
confident i could dump him but i didn't
have to because his partner started
screaming at me stupid [ __ ] the
gang members that were on the street
like garcinia
you know it was uh it was good stuff and
so he ended up getting fired so then he
became a a sheriff uniform sheriff right
yeah patrol
and then he got uh he got asked by
another uh high profile detective uh
frank salerno who caught the hillside
strangler yeah yeah uh bianchi and bono
and then he said you want to be my
partner yeah i had been transferred up
to homicide because my specialty was
gangs
and after doing that for a couple years
then salerno approached me because i was
in homicide and asked me if i wanted to
be his partner
and i was like [ __ ] yes you know that's
creme de la creme right it's top tier so
the nightstalker documentary that's on
netflix yeah it's out right now yeah
that a year ago probably came out a year
ago january 14th and uh that's where i
saw it like you know my publicist was
like have you seen that night talking
i've already seen it three times in that
same day right
you know and uh gil was there with with
uh frank and then gill was the first
person to say this is the same guy
and everybody else said no no it's two
guys and he goes no [ __ ] that it's the
same guy yeah and and they
you would when he left the room they'd
go that guy's [ __ ] full of [ __ ] man
there's not one guy doing this [ __ ]
two guys what did they think it was just
two is just two they thought there's no
way one dude could have done all that
everything done when you investigate
anything and anything you do even in
comedy everything is predicated on
criminal history with this work but it
won't work well nobody in criminal
history had been documented doing
what i was alleging he was doing
you know pedophiles stick to stick the
kids yeah
either girls or boys this guy was doing
both
he was
in his manners of killing it was guns
knives shot foot striking manual
ligature strangulation he just crossed
all the lines
but there were certain things that were
there
that i could see was one man and the
other guys were saying you're full of
[ __ ] you're punk trying to make a name
of yours we talked about this before
it's funny that the dude angelo i play
golf with he goes i'm gonna go back on
the podcast where you guys aren't
talking about death or what else did he
say yeah
but i'm just interested i used to work
at northridge in the in the mid 80s when
he was on his [ __ ] tear and the thing
was you know there was no internet on
this [ __ ] you radio and tv
but
you knew he was out there and he would
hit in northridge and then when you got
out of work everybody just got the [ __ ]
back to their house
but there was like a [ __ ] feeling in
the valley of this dude and the fear
that he's everywhere and he would
[ __ ] deliver i'd be like this dude is
out there you think he'd be like no you
know they're [ __ ] on me he would
[ __ ] hit wow that's so creepy people
expected him to hit and he would hit
what was his number what did his number
end up being he ended up killing 14
people here that we're aware of we
dropped one in the interest of justice
he says he was good for four more that
we weren't aware of
we looked at actually eight
more
but there wasn't enough physical
evidence to go ahead and link them
so if we didn't have enough where we
knew we'd get a conviction we didn't we
wouldn't mess with it because we didn't
find anymore huh yeah we didn't want
somebody to say
we didn't want to lose a couple of cases
and sway the jurors hey maybe if they
were wrong on these maybe they'd be
wrong over here
so unless it was a solid case we didn't
take it he told me
that after in custody about seven years
he'd be willing to talk
openly about the other ones that we
weren't aware of and then he got pissed
off and he didn't want to talk to him
anymore
why he just
because he got married when he was in
custody
and so the news media how does that
happen this [ __ ] loves this dude
they get a lot right that you've got a
lot of a lot of women on it and they
always do that
like legit women he had some good
looking women following him one day it's
like bundy same thing right yeah women
tell me about the the the ladies that
work there ladies in court one day we
had a lot of visitors coming to court
they just want to see what was going on
two ladies dressed to the tens they were
attorneys no doubt little briefcases
they come in they sit down there and
they're gorgeous both of them
very business-like richard would walk
into the courtroom and every time we
walked in he'd scan the ladies
see who we wanted to look at on the way
out take his time
and so now it's time i get a phone call
they call me up to the bailiff i go up
i'm talking on the phone and i'm looking
and it's time for richard to walk out
now he goes back and he locks eyes with
the two broads that had walked in two
ladies had walked and one of them
sitting right on a corner
and he looks and smiles at her she looks
at him blows him a kiss and opens up her
legs
and i just couldn't believe it i told i
went back i told my partner [ __ ]
arrest me
you know it was just incredible he did
have uh what does this say about
beautiful women
and and he marries they're crazy like
bad guys and they married an ugly one
too did he yeah she was ugly and
and he got pissed off because the news
media came to me and you know what do
you think about this and i said it was i
thought it was a mockery of the criminal
justice system he wasn't in in there for
rehab he was in their
sense of death yeah and why
uh do we have to do anything and it was
a mockery of the sacrament of marriage
because his marriage would never be
consummated
right you know so it just made it all
worthless and so do they have rights
like that in prison where you where you
can get married and you can have
visitors or you can have visitors
doesn't depend on your level of crime
right you can't have conjugal visits on
death row but it depends on your level
right doesn't it you have to get
approved by the judge to get a
controversial visit right it's not
standard is it you you can't my
understanding i i won't say for sure my
understanding
inmates on death row
cannot have conjugal businesses right
other inmates can have kind of they [ __ ]
them in the shower they've catches
that's like part of the that's part of
that's part of the
extras that's a conjugal surprise
that's so surprising that soapy surprise
yeah and and richard
uh the way they visited over there
you know it's kind of out in the open
everybody came out to visit the same
spot
and the other inmates i was told
that they hated they all wanted him dead
because when
if he was out there on a visit
and somebody else came by to visit they
had their wives or anybody else
he would take his whacker out and start
playing with himself expose himself to
the other visitors yeah sounds like they
hated him they want to kill him wow damn
it's not like something there's no rules
right no i miss prison yeah i mean what
are you going to do today i'm not here
to make friends what did they say that
uh that had to jerk off on my friends
yeah they're the the the wolf
lyle and uh um
eric eric uh menendez menendez were at
uh were they were they stated county
jail no yeah they were in county jail
before they got convicted and that they
were talking to the lawyers that richard
ramirez walked by
and they both were like
wait those are the kids they killed
their parents
sean penn was in the in the jail right
across the hallway from richard
wow
i don't know what shot people think that
drinking and driving about abuse yeah it
wasn't long it wasn't there for long it
was just in there for a few days but
they were right right along and so
richard wanted to contact him sean
my understanding didn't want to have
anything to do with richard
i drove by that house when i first moved
to l.a you know in beverly hills yeah
it's
your wife with you she said let's go
it's not like canada or something it's
not a major road in beverly hills i
don't remember but you could still drive
by the house but the house is still
there
and i was thinking about that like
we're talking to this on my podcast
about living in your house being haunted
and do they have to tell you or not i
think there's something like the next
resident they have to tell but after
that i don't think they don't ownership
is different than our apartment rentals
they have to tell you stuff
they have to do with homes they have to
do with homes here too yeah
well if somebody died in the house they
have to tell you yeah but from way back
some imagine i showed you all the stuff
on my phone right there
my landlord my first landlord in west
hollywood this old little italian lady
west hollywood i was living in west
hollywood
and she's one of the first things she's
like are you gay and i was like no i'm
not gay and she's like oh thank god and
i was like
you know there's west hollywood
everybody's gay
i was like you're in the wrong business
if you this is where you have your
building and she said the the with the
man who was in this he or he died before
he you come here i was like oh [ __ ] oh
that's terrible she goes of aids but you
know he was gay and i was like oh okay
the way she
homophobic landlord in the middle of
west hollywood i was like what are you
doing in this neighborhood
yeah yeah i was like you're in the wrong
spot sell the building if you don't like
i tell you what after listening to the
podcast
and i've heard his stories and i've been
in his house yeah but after listening
that all the man it starts sinking in
man i could never i don't care how drunk
i got i could never spend the night in
this house yeah i'd hey george just let
me sleep outside the front door let me
tell you we'll be on the porch we
cleared them pretty much all out and the
lady said that there was a couple of
evil like the poltergeists are the ones
that
like you told me not to call anybody i
would call people and they would they
would hear noises and stuff and she said
don't call anybody anymore but
that knocking the lie i was so loud
you think now it's gone you think it's
okay it's pretty much gone but a couple
of nights you know because the floor is
old you know
but
i'm a light sleeper so i'll be sleeping
and then you'll hear like
like like a step one step
and you're like [ __ ] so whoever whatever
spirit that is
you can't see but has enough respect for
me to only take one step it's not going
yeah
that's it's a trip man it's a trip to
live in that house do you ever think
they're [ __ ] with you like when they
do one step do you ever think like a a
spirit knows that one step is more
scarier
that's what i mean i'd be [ __ ] with
people so much if i was a spirit i
wouldn't run through the house i would
pull on one thing every like few days
just the one that the one that really
got me was when when my daughter mayan
said
you know there's a poltergeist app on
tick tock and i said there is and then i
did it in the room and something showed
up in front of the
screen me and then it disappeared i'm
like holy [ __ ]
i'm out like what the [ __ ] is that
there's no way i could do both i
couldn't hold it like this and then run
my own hand over it like and i was like
it took me years to get over the [ __ ]
yorona oh now you're gonna lay this [ __ ]
on me yeah yeah forget about it you got
to go to his house go to his house and
go check it out and and he's got a
painting he's got
some demonic painting on your wall he
said get rid of that [ __ ] thing
that's what bringing them all together
talk
which one was that one the one that's uh
not the one that's the car the cops
shooting they said it looks like an
officer involved shooting right yeah it
is yeah the one on the other side on us
on the north oh that's that's carlos
armanis man that's that's like the the
chicano painter what is it an image of
um a [ __ ] devil you know what yeah
that guy was a chicano guy east la big
cheech was the guy who turned me on to
him you know because cheech was an art
collector
and and he i think he knew
carlos
and uh
listen when you're married and you have
a show on tv
uh money is no object
so ann got me a smaller painting and i
got the big one that's hanging there i
got a divorce and i said how much was
that she goes you don't want to know
yeah
i don't want to know right now [ __ ] but
when we get divorced yeah i want to know
and there was a i go what's that it was
it was a french like a sh
she goes that hung in a chateau
in the 1500s in paris and i said you
know what i'm going to tell you
before i even ask you i don't want to go
home about that yeah no
they shipped it or it was in the chateau
oh in the 1500s is it any of these i
just looked up some of this
it is as a matter of fact um
as a matter of fact
that painting was probably
it's not in there okay 250 000
then it's probably worth a million now
jesus christ and uh it was his favorite
painting and anne asked his
widow
what what she would possibly sell and i
believe
uh she sold that
painting george didn't know until it was
up on the wall
this is this is how much money ann spent
it you know god bless
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] the guys that worked
on my house were from england they
listened to books on tape you all know
when the [ __ ] expensive the
guys out hiring listen to mexican music
yeah yeah yeah they're a little boombox
yeah they're listening to books on tape
airpods in there yeah they're doing
they're doing venetian blasters
i miss that
[ __ ] [ __ ] books on tape what's the
most expensive thing that you've bought
or that's been bought by you unknowingly
is it art like that
a quarter of a million is heavy for ours
when we met i wasn't you know i was a
young comedian struggling i remember
there was a store called address
on wilshire and i bought a die a
sapphire and two small settings as the
engagement ring
and oh
and 12 years later a guy came with a
suitcase with a security guard and she
bought a diamond that was maybe 400 000.
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
bought a condo to wear around
that's the wildest [ __ ] and with that
divorce she said [ __ ] him and she took
it out and used it now to have
helicopters land from vietnam
and you know
it's one of those where it's
400 at one time but she goes okay mr
porsche mr lakeside mr pebble b oh okay
all right all right we're keeping a
tally now yeah but those are active
things uh
stone that's
so wild to me i only i only i i always
understand indulging with money on
things that you really really get to use
i never i never criticize because i'm
always like if you're going to use it
it's expensive it's fun but man a stone
is so wild to me i saw a girl last night
at the laker game that walked onto the
floor it was like four four rappers or
you know yeah and these dudes i mean the
amount of chains and [ __ ] but the one
girl that was trailing all these dudes
in my life i've never seen i mean it was
i mean no [ __ ] was a silver dollar the
size the diamond was a silver dollar
that's how big it was on her hand and i
was like god damn it have been a million
or two right in a in a stone and what
but it's never go it's you can't do
anything you can't sell you're not gonna
get your money back you can get robbed
is all you can get
i don't even think like that i can't
you're talking big ass old guys you're
talking a million dollar penny so so i
can't even afford to go to the [ __ ]
laker games
get him to the laker game man wear
watches and stuff growing up do you have
a chain no you know what you know it's
funny well yeah i had a chain when i was
young and then
then when i got older
i just i never wore jewelry and my dad
never wore a lot of jewelry either he
like actually comes from a thing where
you know like you see somebody like your
dad didn't do it maybe your brother
didn't do it somebody didn't do it then
you grow up and you're like nah we our
family didn't wear a lot of we never
wore jewelry like i have watches i have
a few nice watches and i never wear them
and it's so silly i don't i don't even
know why i used to love
the idea of them but i'd wear them to
like a nice dinner with my lady on a
date and then i sometimes would wear
them to shows but i would feel guilty
you know because it was a nice watch so
i'd feel like man if someone else sees
me i'm on my come up in comedy they're
gonna hate me right if they see me with
a nice watch because you know that
comedy is this weird once you get to a
level no one cares anymore but when
you're first getting up and you get a
couple bucks and i bought a watch for my
first sitcom money because i was proud i
was like man i wants one thing nice i
was living in a shitty little apartment
i had a [ __ ] car what were you was
that
uh
2009 or 10. okay and how show was it it
was called mixology on abc it was a one
season show
but it was my first sitcom and i got my
first check and i was like
man i want to watch i want like one nice
watch and i bought it and i was so
scared to wear it to the store but when
i would go on the road i could wear it
when i left l.a i would wear it because
i was like nobody can judge me i'm gone
i'm not in l.a but when i go to the club
with the improv of the store i was just
scared of [ __ ] i didn't want someone
to be like yeah sure this month you know
i because the competition is so thick in
comedy people hate people love to see
you on the come up but they hate to see
it happening you know they're proud of
you but they don't want to watch you do
it they don't want to know you have a
little bit of money
what happened oh god did it fall off
yeah that's right
somehow somehow they would they don't
want to see you
they want that like every comic i think
this is in most industries i mean
most peers
you want your friends to rise in
whatever ranks it is but
there's a degree of their rise where
they're like [ __ ] that guy everyone does
that it's just it's uh it's hard to get
away from i don't know for some reason
to pull you down yes they're crabs in a
bucket yeah
the moment you see someone get too too
famous in society we want to shoot them
out of the sky you love to boost them up
and then when they get too big
they you want to shoot them down and
you're a stranger think when your
friends do it it's weird when someone
you know kind of
hates on you because you've got
something that's what's wild that's it
so yeah
because i'll say this because
um
you know i didn't we don't have any more
advantages than anybody else like you're
it's just your work
like you know i was i was uh i started
in 79 arsenio was in 89 i started doing
arsenio's
and then
he stopped at 95 so 95 and 99 were my
darkest
years when i was drinking
and i was going nowhere and i remember
thinking man i became the last [ __ ]
thing i wanted to be which is a road
comedian
and i just won new year's eve i decided
you know i'm just going to start
worrying less about [ __ ] everybody
else and only worry about myself i still
worry about i used to read people the
[ __ ] empire and my wife would buy it
i was worried about everybody else man
it's like this is this can't be [ __ ]
healthy so 1 98.99 i'm like you know
what and it was and it was almost like
drugs getting off drugs because you'd be
like what's that is that people might oh
no no i'm okay
no no i don't want to
get not trying to quit
you're like is that the trade and i
decided to [ __ ] worry less about
what's going on and worry more about
what's going on with me and it [ __ ]
that works i can change man yeah you
can't worry about somebody else you
[ __ ] bragging on somebody it's like a
negative [ __ ] you're like you know how
you know they can [ __ ] him but think
about how bad social media is now for
people on the right i was just going to
ask if you found it like is it harder
now no because right because he's out he
is already at a point where that
do you know what i mean that that's the
way
but the youngest guys in comedy that
they have to deal with it constantly and
they used to [ __ ] on tick tock
that
aren't bad in 15 seconds yeah yeah like
they can't do anything beyond that but
like that little dude that came in here
that's not that little dude but the dude
that does me leon that motherfucker's
got a whole [ __ ] house in the hills
yeah he
i mean he made his he made his thing
doing me he does like impressions of
like women
here but you should be able to tax that
yeah
of the other characters he plays
when he's a teacher when he's this when
he you know but he made his his
he made a hit doing you still
still do it yeah
tick tock tick tock is the thing that's
going i mean that's the next
generation's thing they break they break
music
so wait wait say his name again this kid
leo gonzalez leo gonzalez he does me
trying to find my car let's see
he's like this is george lopez trying to
find his car there's a part of it that's
flattering though right isn't it it's
nice
right it's nice that someone's doing it
all right it's there's a part of it
that's flat i can tell right now he's
pissed off he didn't like it that's a
part of it that's flattering it's got to
be but then i know i'm sure there's a
part of it that you're like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you a little bit yeah
a little bit
let's see
oh i've seen this kid
after i delivered a joke
yeah but yeah i seen this dude
he's right
you just did it just now yeah just there
you go he did one together because he
was on the pockets like he said they did
one together after we do one together
here he's like doing it uh where leah's
doing like i don't know
how old is
this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and he's living a pretty good life you
know what uh uh there's a there's an
actress that used to follow me and uh we
went out a couple times and she doesn't
follow him anymore but she follows him
it's like hey
[Laughter]
i want the [ __ ] imitator i want real
crap i'll take the [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm the
original i'm the one i want lobster i'll
take some yeah give it an imitation so
you get a imitation crap
out of black mirror is like they don't
follow you they follow the person who's
famous
it's a trip because as
i move closer to the end and you see the
guys coming up in the beginning it's a
whole different oh yeah does it it's all
about let me add does it bother you
personally you've paid your dues both
make fun of me to have a guy to have
no not make fun of you but all these
young guys on tick tock they're getting
all this fame and they're getting money
out of it you know
without paying their dues
now you know what man
anybody who's ever stepped on a stage
has paid if you take one step and you go
up there and you talk for five minutes
like get the [ __ ] out you paid dues
right there because that's an experience
you will never forget and you'll be like
hey tell by that time you did comedy oh
we're at this bar in chicago i went up
there trying to i thought i was going to
be funny they [ __ ] threw [ __ ] at me
and it's traumatic for the rest of your
life yeah
it has to exist i mean like
this is his that has to exist as much as
the veteran that puts in
20 years and then pops has to exist it's
that's the balance because these two
things serve as totally different things
did you see uh
that show dave
yeah yeah that's the show i did yeah
okay it's still going on yeah we're
gonna do another season
in june we'll do our third season
here's the thing because people become
like
creatures of their shows like if you
watch like maybe succession
and maybe you might not even see dave or
or or
i think you might like it i watched it i
bought the first season i won the second
season
i think it's great man i mean it's so
funny man is your car are you gay or not
gay
that's funny that you say that i joked
about it because i said i said you're
not going to let me get a girl this
whole show and he's like we're going to
work on something for the third season i
said
because because i it couldn't because
who knows yeah because you guys are
friends but but there's a little bit of
like when guys are friends yeah there's
something
it is so funny they throw he throws a
lot of that [ __ ] in there i think he
does that just to [ __ ] with people i
think he thinks that's funny to [ __ ]
with people on that but for me i said in
the third season i said i better get
something you better throw me something
right
it's too vague man and your character
like uh uh it's funny when they show you
as a kid oh yeah yeah they give you some
of that they show them as a kid and they
give them some of the traits that he had
which i think is [ __ ] wrong too like
yeah
with no beard nothing did a little
reddish hair red headquarters and he's
talking as a kid in the lunchroom and
you're like oh [ __ ] that's him because
yeah
i like when they do i mean
they're gonna i hope the third season
the explores
bigger and bigger and bigger because you
know like at some point these shows that
are about the business because it's
about the rap world and the
entertainment world
like entourage at some point you don't
give a [ __ ] about the business on the
show you want to see more about the
people on the show which i hope we get
more into because the business side of
the show uh people don't really give a
[ __ ] about i think like entourage was
funniest or those shows are the funniest
when the characters have a funny
character story built out that doesn't
have to do with hollywood as much it's
more about
that outside world so if we get into
that i mean what was uh brilliant i
thought is that
you know he's a rapper he's jewish
rapper
and they give him the name and then he's
like his girl's like rap i never heard
you rap he's like nah you know he
doesn't want to do it yeah he's
embarrassed you're comfortable doing it
and then he goes in the studio
and they you know they're [ __ ]
clowning them and then he does it and he
lights it up [ __ ] brilliant man that
was what yeah that was when we did the
first that was uh
yg and um yeah the camera remember the
other dude but yg and a bunch of dudes
you know look no disrespect to them
they're the [ __ ] but they they brought a
whole crew and some of the dudes on the
crew
brought real guns to the show
and they were like we can't have that
inside this studio dude
and they weren't they weren't coming out
of the set i think they were just people
that wanted to come kick it with him
that were like when they did the studio
they oh my god but it's so funny to
think that you're like yeah man if you
want the real deal you're going to get
the real d the real deal you know i mean
there's no facade with a lot of these
guys that's that is what it is
and we shot a lot of time i mean we shot
uh a ton of that show in south la so if
we ever did anything with guys that were
affiliated it was real i mean it was
like there was no
there this weird line of hollywood that
people that work in hollywood that are
affiliated
do you know what i mean like snoop is
affiliated but he works in hollywood
yeah and it's this weird balance but he
knows guys that will still come
real and i mean there's that weird line
man so when i was doing uh the talk show
like 2009-10 audrey plaza and i on a
saturday
there was a there was a like a hood tour
almost like a tmz tour of hollywood but
it was hood it was gang
i was a gang affiliated tour south
central so they presented it to me i
said let's do it the guy came on
saturday we got in there
audrey aubry and i and then i had a
little white girl assistant and we're in
there and the guy saying you know up
here where snoop did this they're
getting like the ice cube over here and
that's like but it's all about and we go
to
the jungle
where they shot in that cul-de-sac
where denzel washington's
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so king kong
king kong [ __ ] training
so aubry did that scene in the
cul-de-sac
george come back cause i left it she's
like you [ __ ] i will have you
like going off on the street
and we get out and they had to ask those
dudes that we could be on the street
correct and they knew me
that respect i have respect for them and
then a little white girl goes
as her ad-lib
can george get a cheetah up in this
[ __ ] and these dudes went [ __ ] george
and like i was like we're just messing
around but when he said [ __ ] george yeah
yeah that wasn't that was that was real
oh
yeah yeah
yeah i'd have been like let's go we
gotta go we gotta go we haven't gotten
over there like what happened right
there oh this dude got capped uh like
what's today's sunday uh saturday's
friday yeah you're like [ __ ] you have to
check in when you know that you know
that you know that area they don't [ __ ]
around man
when be real was sitting right there and
be real came in here
and be reals from here and i always
thought lapd was the people he had to
look out for and he's like oh hell no
man sheriff would come and [ __ ] roust
you you lied to a sheriff i could beat
your ass man if you don't lie to a shirt
because you lied to lapd but you don't
lie to a sheriff
and uh they had a little respect for the
sheriffs
i sat right there i was like no [ __ ]
like i didn't know i was like what the
[ __ ]
you guys you guys don't like each other
the sheriff and i like don't they don't
oh no no that's that's
friendly rivalry that's all it is
up on the top level before we have
what's going on but
up at the top level there was always
you know bumping heads yeah when we did
the night stalker case first thing we
did with our counterparts from lapd we
said let's we just sat down and said
okay we don't give a [ __ ] what they say
up on top
we keep nothing from each other we work
the case we share information
and it was the best operation we've ever
had okay so check this out
so
when richard ramirez was out there
these dudes like were in jeopardy
because you know you don't know if that
[ __ ] is going to come and try to
take you know try to take somebody in
your family yeah he knows where you live
so his so gil's family left like he's
like hey you guys got to get out of here
all this [ __ ] is going on because it's
not safe here so gil's at his house in
the middle of the night and he hears a
noise
and he gets up and he gets his gun he's
got his he's got his gun and he's he's
got his back against the wall
because that's how they do it and in the
middle of the night his phone rings and
i said how [ __ ] high did you jump is
that scared off damn [ __ ] out of me man
3 30 in the morning i'll never forget
imagine that like you're you hear
something and you're like this and
you're looking around the phone rings
i'm just gonna start shooting at the
phone
channel five john wayne there was a
movie he spoke hero who was that who who
called you do you think it was it was
the office calling me telling me to call
linda arthur my good friend who was on
the documentary yeah she was a deputy
she lived right across from sophie
dickman who was one of our victims
she was on july the 7th
and
she had been
raped she had been burglarized she had
been robbed then she drugged she was
handcuffed to the bed drug her bed at
the window and started yelling mrs
arthur or mrs arthur because my friend
linda arthur who was a deputy lived
right across from her linda's husband
had just been murdered june 1st
and this is july 7th she called
and she was working on crime lab at the
time she'd been out on some of the
murder scenes with me
she was my friend i'd gone through the
academy with her husband
they called me up and they said call
into arthur at home here's her number
yeah and she calls this all in your
neighborhood no this was i was living at
that time in roland heights in monterey
park
and they just said
she says gil i think you got to come
down here
lady cross street just got robbed and
raped and i think it's part of what
you're working on it was just this
[ __ ] worked alone
yes and uh he was mostly when i was it
mostly in the valley no it was all over
it was everywhere everywhere
when i woke up exactly you know because
uh
homicide cops
nurses
first thing they do something happens
what time is it yeah because you always
want to document everything
when i jump i look 3 30 in the morning
i get back in bed and i'm saying
what the [ __ ] is he doing right now this
is [ __ ] with me you know it's really
i can't call the cops because
if i clear nobody's here they're gonna
think i'm nuts right you know but
subconsciously i just thought somebody
was in my house so i cleared my house
get back in bit and now you know i gotta
call up over there
and
so i gotta go check it out but i'm
sitting there what the [ __ ] is going on
sophie dickman will say
at 3 30 in the morning he started
sodomizing her she looked at the clock
because she was a nurse
she says 3 30 in the morning he was
right there in the hood
yeah so it was right by him
it was uh it was kind of tough
it was just a crazy eye that's nuts man
just to think about it
and also your mind's gonna play some
tricks on you too and like they're it's
not gonna help because you're
overthinking it anyway oh that's all i
want if you're looking for it it's gonna
be there type of thing when the
documentary finally dropped i apologize
to my wife because
the job was is i thought
your job is the house and the kids my
job is to find this killer
and so i paid no attention to her and
the kids
and after watching the documentary i
apologized to her because i said i'd
never thought of and i hadn't factored
in the fear factor
i wasn't there to protect you she was
there all by herself she was crying it
was a tough time
so i
asked for forgiveness you know and
she was kind enough to say okay it's all
right she gave it to you yeah that's
that's wild man i still tell her we got
the wrong guy once once here i tell her
we got the wrong guy ever move out again
and that was over there at that cecil
hotel downtown oh yeah crazy ass hotel
that they're trying to stay up they
change their name stay on main oh yeah
this is where
the girls it still says cecil on the
side yeah
they remodeled it they've they've done a
bunch of it's a beautiful hotel inside
but but it's i'm gonna take my wife
there next week thank you yeah they got
good rates right now man thank you man
like you go in the room
and they're i mean it's ominous driving
by it you can never scratch that off
that label is going to be there
no matter how what you do to it even
alexandria over there down down there
too because purple rain they shot in
minneapolis but they shot some of it on
in downtown l.a is that right alexandria
that's right you and momo said yeah
there's some noises down there momo's
talking about the alexander one yeah
momo's got uh
um paranormal stuff
see you get into that so deep i i like
it
i actually asked
um
aj barrero who's a who's uh i'm sure he
said
okay
um
you have aj aj gonna come down
just a single text that says definitely
haunted
definitely haunted he'll come in here
and say this place is on
this place that's what we'll say okay so
i found this picture of bob saget and me
and whoopi and john oliver i saw that
you posted it and let me show you man
that's sad
yeah let me show you a legend that was
awesome
i didn't know who john oliver was though
uh you know who he is now though look at
this no i just saw it this morning uh
last week tonight on each other
it's like uh yeah it's why i mean it's a
weekly nightly sort of show kind of
daily
look at the exposure of this picture
it's half and light it happened oh dude
you know what's really tragic about
about the bob thing other than that
and i can have everything
the real tragic thing is uh
his post yesterday after doing shows was
so
beautiful yeah as a guy who's been doing
it since the late 70s which i met him in
to be
in
2022 first show 2022
and
to put those thoughts down yeah as to
how he felt to do his first showing he
was so excited he was like man i did an
hour and a half i couldn't believe it
you know it's like
it was like he was feeling something
which is wild because you know if he was
feeling not well he wouldn't have said
anything so what's strange is he must
have been feeling great which is even
more strange to me because you wouldn't
tweet out how wonderful it felt to do
your set again if you were like man
i'm not feeling right the set wasn't
good i'm a little off do you know what i
mean i don't say i go into disappearance
mode when i'm having a if when it's
tough on the road or long gigs or
the shows are okay you don't say [ __ ]
online he must have had he must have
been vibing and then
i don't know who knows we'll find out
what happens later but it's a bummer
this is shitty man
and i didn't know the dude that's why i
didn't really kind of say anything about
him publicly because
i don't know him on a personal level but
well man we always it's funny how we
always
found you know he was always because he
would be like what do you see right here
he's like uh
ah
yeah i want to spoon you like two men
you know yeah yeah yeah i mean that's
bob back he said give me let's get back
to a bunk bed or something like that
yeah yeah let's go to bunk bed and we'll
you know we'll get better i mean
man you know like you i didn't know the
man i've seen him and now yeah here we
did his podcast i really felt bad
for george
uh cedric was very vocal and you know he
he put some some people very
high profile comedians and people in the
business were saying
uh
nice stuff about him so i was more
concerned my my feelings are certainly
with his family and yeah i didn't know
him personally but my feelings were
with george with cedric all these other
people that really were touched because
it's close to the loss of a friend yeah
yeah it is wild when it's
he became one of those dudes man like
that would always
be like how are you like you know you're
good man like he was worried about i
drank too much and then he's worried
that i was alone like he was trying to
find somebody for me and i said and he
was alone and then he met somebody
and we talked about that
how he didn't think he was going to get
married again and how
he he just didn't want to be alone for
the rest of his life and that he met
somebody and they were in love man it's
like you know
whatever whatever is in charge of
whatever's going on with us it
it could take you at your lowest point
or it can take you when you're in a
great point in your life oh no
absolutely and you're like which is
better
honestly i don't probably the highest
point maybe i don't want to go when i'm
low and then you know
like
he was more concerned about me
last week than i was about myself like
he was like are you all right you know
and
like that's pretty [ __ ] amazing man
yeah those those people are are worth
their weight in gold the ones who like
ask you how you're doing they'll be like
but no how are you doing
yeah he's a great one yeah man
and forever like he's been around like
betty while you say hey on the view that
i why is betty white so important too
because she's been around my whole life
yeah like you watch password in the
summer with your friends and i [ __ ]
laughing and [ __ ] and bob too man like i
went to the comedy store in 1979 and
[ __ ] bob was one of the first
dudes i met and he was cool i mean like
[ __ ] guy was good back then did then
he get you know in the 80s and he got
[ __ ] america's funniest home bidders
and then when i came up he would see
like hey it's like it's like
it's almost like you know if you're in
the if you're in the like donnie bros go
like you're on the [ __ ] bottom you're
chipping [ __ ] parking meters and then
you do whatever you make it up and you
get made like you're you're with those
dudes man like when i met dennis miller
like the first time he shook my hand he
goes hey welcome welcome aboard like
he's like you know you [ __ ] made it
up
like welcome aboard man you're one of us
yeah and you're like you're [ __ ]
right i want it you know
that's what happens yeah
yeah he was on for a while he was on for
a long time i mean he's been around he
[ __ ] left funny his home videos
yeah like left and everybody thought he
was clean
it was funny for me when i used to go to
the lab factory and people couldn't
believe the [ __ ] he would say
you talk about [ __ ] the olsen twins
and it was the funny
they couldn't wrap their head around
they were like this isn't the funniest
videos guy is it yeah they would come to
me and they go hey man you know that
dude for the funniest one what's his
name bob and sag i said yeah and he's
like i saw him that's [ __ ] i
said yes yeah the dirt was he funny goes
in the beginning no and then yes it's
like yeah but of course like a shock
yeah they can't believe it
he had earned his [ __ ] stripes man
like he'd been doing it
a long time that long and then we talked
about he would do my guitar gently weeps
like back in the day and he turned the
thing he had a wire to type on the in
the podcast and he would do oh my and
the guitar would water would come out of
the guitar
and i said i remember you he goes i
[ __ ] still do it in that picture that
he was in uh orlando the guitars on the
uh he was doing it oh yeah i gotta still
do it
wow and i said how did you do that man
he goes i had like some bladder on my on
my stomach and i had a [ __ ] aquarium
tube and when i turned the knob i pushed
the guitar towards it pushed the watch
great but they were killers man those
guys killed a bunch of stuff for him
doing stuff at danger fields back in the
day yeah riding was riding yeah rodney
liked him a lot i think he's because he
was really fast i think his style was
fast
he would get into that uh
that thing where he'd go and i want to
love you but not like a man as a woman
like a man as a man we get hawaiian
shirts we'll get some bunk beds and
we'll get some kfc we'll spend the night
like that that like
he'd get that [ __ ] and then he would get
that [ __ ] going yeah and you didn't know
what he was going to say but it was it
was just kind of his cadence you know
yeah
rest in peace to that dude man yeah
those are all like hey you know what you
went to vietnam we're warriors in
another
in that business where one goes and you
feel yeah you feel it it's wild even if
you don't really like i didn't even know
him but it's just weird to feel it
because you know i don't know it makes
you question a lot of [ __ ] because we're
doing it and you i every comic on earth
thinks about passing away on the road in
hotels every comic is like
it doesn't matter how good the tour is
how bad the tour is
you think about it you think about being
in a hotel you're in another city you're
out you're away from home or your family
and your friends and you're and i always
call you yeah man it always passes
through your mind
just another hotel somewhere you know uh
robin harris
in the uh did do the right thing he
played a sweet dick willie those guys
that would sit around in front of me but
mike tyson my boy's got a head like a
pit bull like
robin harris was on his way up like on
his way up and he was uh
he did uh a house party played the dad
and
he's hilarious
he used to work at the bank and i worked
in northridge and i met him somewhere
and he's like yo come and see me at el
altorito
on wilshire
there was an el torito by by 97.1 klsx
over there and there was an el torito on
wednesdays they did
comedy and he worked at the bank and he
went up there
and for an hour just ripped into people
and i sat there man he's like
yo young blood you want to go there i
said [ __ ] you man i ain't going up there
and he was he was brilliant man yeah
brilliant he started doing those movies
he was in chicago and they went to go
look on look look at him he had a show
and
like greg gerald passed away in the
hotel room another hotel
i said you stay i used to stay in that
hotel when you go do stress factory you
stay in that same hotel i thought about
that all the time that's those dismal
things that you're like man man the road
is so weird you know what man because we
all touch each other in a weird way you
all have touched a comic and even if
you've never met you know you know them
somehow you've connected somewhere there
was a dude named um
kane lopez
who was like a young young guy
and uh
i had found out that he was sick i
didn't know him
but i'd seen him up in sacramento but
brian kellen knew him and i said hey man
you know cain lopez and he goes yeah i
said i heard he's not doing very well
man so i think when we land on sunday in
burbank you should go see him and i went
to go see him too i'd never met him and
i went in there and he surprised to see
me
his dad was there i paid for his funeral
man
because
they didn't have the money
and i thought we're soldiers
and that's what yes
so
god bless you yeah man i mean i'm
worried now uh
which is what we should do you know we
should yeah you got to help our yeah
yeah
my my good buddy that i've talked to you
about before the one he's got stage
forge can't stay for uh cancer lung but
he's he's a crazy guy and he's funny so
a great
great great outlook on life you know the
the doctor said we give you uh
we're not gonna operate we can give you
three to three to ten years he says i'll
take six
yeah
and then he sits and he says hey i know
you're going through some [ __ ] so
hey if things go wrong with you he says
are you gonna be pissed off will it
offend you if i go to your services and
i'm sitting right next to your wife with
my arm around her you know so he's a
great guy
when i got to take care of her you know
when i talk to him it's always about not
how he's doing it's how are you doing
yeah i know man always concerned more
for me
and
if i learned nothing else from my dad
that's what my dad was my dad would
he was dying of cancer and he had lung
cancer and he'd sit there how are you
doing with that i'm not doing too good
today forget about me though how are you
how are the kids
you know always concerned for everybody
else that's a great trait it's a noble
feeling when you sit there and say that
but you know this business man can make
you like a cop it could desensitize you
to real feelings because there's a part
of you you have to turn off in order to
entertain yeah and then you have your
wife and you have your kids where they
don't have that part but then you have
to be able to
to co exist with them sure and not want
to go hide which i always wanted i was
always alone anyways so when i was
married i was always upstairs
and you can hide and say like
you know it's part of my process but
it's not it's just you just prefer to be
by yourself yeah
yeah
yeah there's something about being able
to
we get you do have to turn off pieces of
you as a comic so when you have to check
back into reality and feel feelings with
other people
it is weird because the way we have to
temper all that stuff because you're
just used to the [ __ ] even if it's
like let's go have breakfast you know
sunday at 10 we're back by two you're
like how about two [ __ ]
all right yeah yeah where oh
yeah
because you know you people recognize
you're right you're going for yeah yeah
and that's that's a trip too yeah
because all of a sudden it's like hey
are you and then
yeah it's sometimes something it's okay
sometimes and sometimes you're really
not in the mood for it but it you know
i'm always gracious of it i said that
one time i was like those people pay my
mortgage man so i'm happy to see him but
also
sometimes if you're in a shitty mood
right people expect you to be happy and
engaging all the time there's times
where you wish you could
have a tag on that's like not today it's
a shitty day today yeah just we have
shitty days so
up in uh
in silmar at the olympia hospital my
grandmother was in the hospital grandma
raised me
this was like august
of 2009 i was doing my talk i was
getting ready to do my talk show but to
show it syndicated
and
uh
i went in there and i talked to my
grandmother about like just you know she
was in a coma about going and stuff like
that and then
she had passed away
and they were going to take her
downstairs and you know that guy said
you know there's nothing you can do and
i went downstairs and they saw me
downstairs my grandmother just died and
she raised me and they're like hey can
we take a picture with this ah yeah come
on come on take a picture and and you
didn't say like hey my grandmother just
died yeah oh come on yeah it's all right
five or six or whatever then got in my
car i went but i never thought about
saying no because they don't know but
they'll be like [ __ ] that guy that's
weird man it's crazy you're not allowed
to
do what they would turn it off yeah yeah
it's strange sometimes that that it is
strange because you're like
i get it they don't know and if you
explain it to them it's going to be even
weirder you know that you're like hey i
don't want to do that my my
grandmother's dead yeah they're like
yeah but you're a comedian right you're
like yeah [ __ ] it
you're great
yeah yeah they think you're full of [ __ ]
that doesn't matter just hey yeah i
didn't work today i didn't think i was
going to see i got my cat got my kids
right here your grandma died all right
yeah
yeah so so um uh what's in the future
you doing movies or are you doing i did
a couple of movies i did a couple of
netflix movies i did one with kevin hart
which was great i actually did the
remake of that house party movie there
yeah they're putting they're putting out
the like the new generation of it yeah i
did a couple of scenes in that it was
fun but i did a movie with kevin hart
and mark wahlberg that'll come out
because kevin hart does uh dave right
there they're part of he's a pretty
brother he's an ep yeah he's one of
heartbeat is one of the
nine
yeah
that's wild these days every card every
card you're like who's that who's that
[ __ ] dudes in that yeah yeah no it's
it's a it's a heavily pushed show
by the train but i like it i like it i
think it really is phenomenal yeah it's
fun it's a good show we're gonna do that
again in june uh those couple of movies
will come out at some point and then i'm
touring now until um april i think and
then i'm done in april i'm going to take
a month off i'm going to europe for a
month well first oh first of all
no i'm just going to go i just want to
get out i just want to get away for a
while
yeah i want to shoot a special sometime
right before the summer that's the plan
would you do it for net for netflix or
whatever i don't know i think i'm gonna
do it on my own oh yeah i think i'm
gonna do it on my own like i've been
talking about it for a long time um
about self-distribution
just because you know i know i'm not
that big like how like louis puts his
out and you buy his own but i think the
model is great because you're like the
model is great
the money goes to you you control all
the elements no one's telling you what
you can and can't say
there's no like programming ideas they
have to slot you in a way in a month at
a time i just don't want to deal with
that stuff i think i don't know i mean
i'm not 100 but i think i'm going to do
that finish up and then we want to get
away for like a month go to europe and
just disappear for a while and then come
back and shoot season three of dave and
yeah that'll be that that's an awesome
it's an awesome show thank you brother
yeah and how's it going in chicago
you're gonna be at the yeah i'm gonna do
chicago theater but i'm gonna be there
february 5th when is this out is this
out soon uh this is probably next week
monday all right good so yeah february
5th i'm going to be there
uh at the chicago theater
boys coming back to chicago the hometown
show i'm excited some of the chicago
bulls are going to come which makes me
feel like does it have a theater a few
times beautiful it's wild i did it once
with rogan when i used to tour joe rogan
a few times like he would take me out i
did it with him once and i was sitting
back there and the stage manager was
like he said yeah i was like this is
incredible man when it was closed you
know and they kick everyone out and you
just are looking at this empty space
he's like you'll do it
and i was like the [ __ ] out of here man
i thought he was being a smartness he's
like you'll do it man i was like i don't
know man you don't know me you don't
know if i'm gonna be able to do it and
then cut you know two and a half years
later i'm gonna do it in uh
in 1989 we went to we did ski patrol we
did in utah and then roger rose was from
chicago me and roger
paul feig director and steve heidener
went to hang out with roger in chicago
and roger had a buddy larry jacobs that
wrote for letterman letterman was doing
a week at the chicago theater buddy guy
jay leno michael jordan damn and we sat
in the chicago theater and i never
thought
that i would sell that place out four
times or whatever the [ __ ] but it's one
of my it's incredible one of my prizes
it means a lot to me to come home and to
go be able to do it i mean it's because
it's beautiful so pretty man the side
door you you walk upstairs there's
cement stairs and you have that nice
room over there then you walk down and
you turn and you go it's 100 years old
too which is nice it's beautiful he's
showing it to him yeah it's stunning i
haven't seen the inside 100 years old
yeah and it's restored al capone's booth
is still there his booth is
uh of the first row of those those
booths see the you know the the
what are they what do they call those
but actually what's wild is the reason
that it's the furthest left the the
stage manager told me is because across
the street right across the street is uh
a building that one of their affiliates
owned and it was one of the only
buildings at the time that had an
elevator that could go from street level
to basement level so al could get down
and out into a car and be gone and i
said oh if he's you know if it's from
someone in the theater trying to trying
to come get him and he's like no it's
always the cops because the cops always
be like two steps behind him and they
were always chasing him down and stuff
so when he went out for an entertainment
night he'd get away with an hour or two
of being out and then cops would try to
come get him because they know
something's going on he's never seen any
play end yeah no yeah he's always been
half a player intermission is they made
it for him he's got to get out of here
that place is haunted oh sure
i was uh doing a meet and greet
and then you know you're meeting people
right here i'm saying right there and i
felt somebody go like this and i went i
went right there i go something just
touched my right arm right here
and again the usher goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's haunted for sure you can
tell when you go somewhere back to those
old theaters uh man it gives you it
gives you so much weird history there
too that it really like you feel in your
chest when you go to the bowels of them
you'd stay away from that [ __ ] you're
gonna go back no no no you know what
[ __ ] around with it but you feel you
feel something in those rooms they're so
old
and the thousands and thousands of
performers that have been through there
over the years and
it's just you can't help but feel
something you know the stairs are cement
so they're not like they're tile they're
cement so that's immense cement yeah all
the way up down turn right go back down
the stage back up and that room is in
there and you see
whoever uh you know buddy guy you see
yeah uh all the members of whatever band
sitting in that room that you're sitting
there like how it's right there that
feels really it feels wild that's the
same way i feel about the store whenever
whenever i go out on stage there's
always a moment on the main room floor
that i'm like man the guys that used to
tape specials at the stores
when that main room had that hbo special
and it just it's it's weird to think
about that of all these glad you're
doing the chicago theater
congratulations thank you man it's great
to know you man and uh thank you for
doing this appreciate you man did you
introduce him great no we always do that
at the end
do it now thanks thanks so much for
coming out he's the greatest
previously on the podcast today andrew
santino actor podcaster comedian golfer
yeah golfer yeah we got to go play i got
here
yeah let's go i'm in and tune in to uh
his pocket yeah whiskey whiskey ginger
and bad friends me and bobby lee have
one but whiskey ginger is the one where
it's just me george came on and did it
bobby lee is uh we're trying to get him
back on here
he is insane just psycho man he got all
excited because
he came in is that the first very first
show i did with george i didn't even
know i was doing a podcast i was invited
to meet friends and i came in here and i
sat right there and bobby lee's here
and it was really a fun time for me he's
nuts and he is nuts and he shows him and
he said he did not he started crying
literally
and then just picked up his t-shirt and
said [ __ ] stop you made me cry
and and he wiped his tears
and
today in a message that i got from you
he wants to he said to say hello to the
kill he said
bobby said be sure and say hello to gil
and i told jordan i said [ __ ] i pissed
in my pants like a little puppy yeah i
mean he remembered me you know yeah of
course it was fun
and bobby's like you know what did bobby
say like hey [ __ ]
are you are you are you gonna make it
some [ __ ] i said [ __ ] yes finally
somebody you know
uh
how are you gonna make it
oh i'm glad yeah yeah tell girl i said
hi uh you know because out because i was
sick new year's eve [ __ ] and the thing
the thing with that the thing with new
year's eve is
i don't have covert but i have a kidney
transplant upper respiratory and
dehydration and that's those are the
dangers so so i'm at home like and and
like bob like he's like ah you know i'm
okay
so you
if you cancel your [ __ ] [ __ ]
because there's shows and people bought
tickets but if you go hey man i don't
feel really good man i don't think i
should do i don't think i should do it
and they'll be like oh this
motherfucker's trying to bail out on new
year's eve what you're not trying to do
and then you go and when i got up there
half hour in
20 minutes in i was sweating you knew
this is not good
and uh
i sat down and i got back up
andrew i saw a [ __ ] red
[ __ ] streak in front of me i was like
oh the [ __ ] is that and i told my nurse
that he goes yeah you see red right
before you drop yeah you just i was
gonna say i've seen that right before i
pass out yeah you passed out
it's a church
not holy spirit
thank you brother i appreciate you man
my man this is great all right thank you
hey this is so much fun thank you man i
appreciate it
you